we've looked at two out of the three I
advise you not this one this one and
that's to you this one rs stands for
random sample why why is a random sample
useful if you'll simply think doesn't
put a phrase I put down in another color
yeah it works
I want equal representation because that
will be free on twice at least the
random samples aren't perfect right sir
what's better than a rate of samples is
that if you've got a stratified random
sample you'll make sure if they're like
subgroups within your target population
you'll get them all equally okay
ah but for how awesome stratified rate
of samples are it a perfect because it
better if you were here now you're part
of the the customer satisfaction quality
review team for the restaurant so you
want to get a survey of everyone who you
know it comes here to your shopping and
you actually eat seafood and so on see
the oh I know I want to make sure this
is unbiased okay so I don't want to just
pick you know a particular time of day I
don't want to pick just a particular
McDonald's it's rather a spread or lay
out what have you so any oh I should do
a random sample or some kind
won't be the problem with a great
example just a straightforward okay so
if by talking about you later
that was both political but you probably
attend a random sample right a regular
sample depends on I showed you three
ways of getting a random sample do you
remember what they were there are like a
little while ago there was a spreadsheet
there was a calculator and then there
was the okay now foot each of those
but each of those there was kind of a
discussion right so I acid s the the
assumption was I can give dump this to
every single person my target population
and then I can at my own leisure come up
with some random series of numbers maybe
ask those people okay now just think of
a normal day at the restaurants appear
amaze them here you have no idea how
many people are gonna tell your
restaurant
right and even if you were to number
every single one of them as they came
through after they gone they go home
like they spent like five minutes here
and then it's finished okay you don't
get to access them anymore so all of
these approaches are going to be
problematic if you're here you can't
just sort of you know hey everyone stay
what's up until the end of the day and
then I randomly pick up I need something
that will work with this so Last Supper
hanging for the day last seventy for the
date
the last kind of way to get a sample out
of your time population is called a
systematic sample that interestingly
when you look at the word you're like
hold a second systematic is it
systematic the exact opposite of random
and it kind of is right that's just some
that example banks he's he's my
definition which I'd love for you to
write down we write a systematic sample
is taking people or items I'll explain
the items in a second taking people or
items and regular intervals so how would
this work when you're there at markers
okay well suppose you want to interview
survey say 5 percent 5 percent of the of
the people who need at Mack is that day
ok 5 percent well it's easy to get 5
percent without doing any of this stuff
me random numbers by simply saying ok
first thing I'm gonna do is just wait
for people to start coming in wave does
that people start Korean right
as I tick them off as I just count when
I get to the 19th person who's eaten
then I suddenly sit up and I say okay
the last person the 20th person I'm just
gonna interview you because think about
it right if I interview one out of 20 I
don't know how who's the 20 will be I'm
just kidding it's some kind of random
order okay what out 20 is 5% does that
make sense business is pretty quick so
then our interview the 20% and then I
guess some more people roll in and I'll
ignore all of them and then our
interview person number 40 and then
person number 60 now the advantage of
this right so this is um ie the 20th
person the 40th person or 60th person I
don't need to know anything about these
people right and if I do this all day I
will get an equal cross-section of like
breakfast lunch and dinner I won't get
like a bias because I only get the
people who wake up early enough to get
to Magnus for the people who don't wake
up early enough so they've got to go
back a skip breakfast or whatever it is
okay I'm getting a cross section across
the entire day with no prior knowledge
about what these people are like does
that make sense
so despite the fact that you're like
wait I went from random to these are
progressively more structured and more
predictable but all you're trying to do
is get equal representation and this
will do it for me
now one last item before I see clever
questions
I said items not just people of support
isn't this is another important example
if you're doing quality control this is
actually a very very common question if
you are in a factory quality control is
interested in all of the product being
made at your factory okay but checking
every single one I mean if you have
really really high standards then yet
you'll check every single one but
sometimes you can't check every single
one because if for instance you'll make
food and it's like well I have to taste
this kind of thing and make sure well
you can't taste every single one going
out because then you can't sell anything
right so you'll do something like this
right you'll do something with it you
say okay every every 100th cake that
comes out of this weight going to
actually open or not we're gonna taste
it I'm gonna make sure no one kills ever
dies that type of thing to make sure
that the quality control these are sure
okay so even though it's not about this
is sort of getting away from like
surveys and asking you look good so a
kink how is your run through it better
you don't get asked that you're looking
for something but if that it's the same
idea does that make sense
you're systematically going through
you're getting a sample who represents
your whole population does it make sense